[Music]
Deadpool to seize the return of the Merc
with the mouth bigger and badder than
ever before the ryan reynolds led comic
book film packs a punch that secures it
as one of the most entertaining movies
of the year as with most comic book
films there are several Easter eggs and
post-credits scenes that tease potential
sequels and plot lines to come
throughout this video I will be
discussing Deadpool 2's ending as well
as the movie's post-credits II there
will be huge spoilers so I highly
recommend that you wait until you've
seen the film before watching this video
without the way I'm definition and this
is my ending explained video for
Deadpool tube after watching his
girlfriend brutally murdered in front of
him Deadpool is on a suicide mission in
the film's opener he attempts numerous
ways to end his life but is unable to do
so because of his healing factor
mirroring this is cable in the future he
too has had his loved ones ripped from
his arms by the villain fire fist cable
vows to kill his family's murderer
before he ever has the chance to take
their lives and this kicks off the main
flop traveling back in time he hunts
down fire fists as a child before his
powers had fully matured unbeknownst to
him the young boy and Deadpool have
struck up a friendship and the two must
battle one another as one tries to
murder him while Silva tries to protect
him in their first confrontation a cable
takes a memento from Deadpool and this
comes into play in the final act
this led coin was from Deadpool and his
girlfriend's first day and obviously has
a lot of sentimental value for the Merc
with a mouth
as our protagonist friendship with
firefish as early on a prison which uses
collars to new immune powers the boy
comes into contact with the juggernaut
they bond and the duo team up in order
to take down those who wronged him in
his childhood after visits to the
afterlife
Deadpool knows that he must find
Redemption by saving the boy's life
he draws up an uneasy alliance with
cable as neither can take on the
juggernaut head-on and they must work
together as a team even though their
goals are opposite in the final act
cable goes to kill fire fist but before
he can Deadpool jumps in the way of the
bullet and sacrifices himself in order
to save him the character is wearing a
collar that neutered his powers and as
such he is unable to healed and he dies
at the scene he is reunited with his
loved one in heaven so it's a bit of a
happy end
however cable realizes that this is
wrong and travels back in time to place
the lead coin where the bullet would hit
so that it deflects this still allows
Deadpool to show that he was willing to
give his life to save fire fists and to
be the inspiration that the child needed
in order to not become the villain this
move has caused cable sigh machine to be
depleted of energy but he vows to stay
in the present and help where he can
safe in the knowledge that his family
are now safe the movie isn't finished
yet though and the post-credits scene is
arguably the greatest ever put to film
after the time machine is fixed Deadpool
is able to travel through time and write
all the wrongs of his past he ventures
back to save his girlfriend from being
murdered before completely shattering
the fourth wall and killing the version
of himself that appears at the end of
x-men origins Wolverine I absolutely
love this reference and it gets even
better when we watched the character
travel back in time to kill Ryan
Reynolds as he reads the script for
green lanten basically so he could never
make that terrible terrible movie I
thoroughly enjoyed that pool - due to
its crass humor outstanding action
scenes and overall charm I was never a
huge fan of the first film however this
writes a lot of its wrongs and there are
several moments throughout that really
shown for me Josh Brolin was phenomenal
and whilst I don't think that he topped
his Thanos before
moments he still was very good in the
role Deadpool 2 was a blast from start
to finish and I can't wait to watch it
again
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film so if you've seen it please
let me know what you liked and didn't
like about it and tell me if you think
the original is better if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel as I do ending
explain videos across a wide range of
media from TV to games movies and more
they'll definitely be something on the
channel that you love and if you want to
see more then check out my ending
explained videos for Avengers infinity
war and the new Netflix horror family
blood thanks very much for taking the
time to watch this video I'll see you
next time take care peace
you